From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, the story of two Americans who went to South Africa. One's white, one's black. And they went there because there's something about South Africa for them and for many Americans, something familiar and unfamiliar at the same time in a way that makes it mesmerizing.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目讲述的是两名美国人前往南非的故事。一个是白人，一个是黑人。他们去那里是因为南非对他们以及许多美国人来说，有着某种既熟悉又陌生、令人着迷的特质。
Robert Kennedy described this congruence of nations as well as anybody. In 1966, he was visiting South Africa. And he began a speech at the University of Cape Town this way--
罗伯特·肯尼迪对这种国家间的共性描述得非常到位。1966年，他在访问南非时，在开普敦大学的演讲开场白是这样的——
I come here because of my deep interest and affection for a land settled by the Dutch in the mid-17th century, then taken over by the British, and at last independent. A land in which the native inhabitants were at first subdued, but relations with whom remain a problem to this day. A land which was once the importer of slaves and now must struggle to wipe out the last traces of that former bondage. I refer, of course, to the United States of America.
我之所以来到这里，是因为我对这片土地有着深厚的兴趣和情感，它由荷兰人在17世纪中叶定居，后来被英国人接管，最终走向独立。在这片土地上，原住民最初遭到压制，而与他们的关系至今仍是一个问题。这片土地曾是奴隶输入地，而今必须努力消除那种过去奴役的最后痕迹。我所指的，当然是美利坚合众国。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
That stunned pause before the audience begins applauding, I think that's so beautiful. More than England or France or Israel, more than Canada or Japan, when we think of South Africa, it is a more interesting mirror of the United States than nearly any country. I think because we glimpse a distant echo of the most frightening parts of our own country and the most inspiring parts.
在观众开始鼓掌之前那阵令人震撼的沉默，我觉得非常动人。比起英国、法国或以色列，比起加拿大或日本，当我们想到南非时，它几乎比任何其他国家都更能成为美国的一面镜子。我想这是因为我们在南非瞥见了我国最可怕的部分，以及最鼓舞人心的部分。
In the 1950s and '60s, black South Africans looked to the US for inspiration. Lewis Nkosi lived in Sophiatown. He remembers reading American literature like Langston Hughes' Simple Speaks His Mind.
在20世纪50年代和60年代，南非黑人曾向美国寻求灵感。刘易斯·恩科西曾住在索菲亚镇。他记得阅读过兰斯顿·休斯的《简单说出他的心声》等美国文学作品。
We used to laugh so much about what he was saying, because it sounded to us like this was Johannesburg. And listening to the music, the films like Stormy Weather were just speaking for us.
我们过去常对他所说的内容开怀大笑，因为在我们听来，那简直就是约翰内斯堡。听着那些音乐，像《狂风暴雨》这样的电影，简直就是在替我们发声。
"Harlem was like our neighborhood," Lewis Nkosi says. Black South Africans in Sophiatown listened to Dizzy Gillespie and Charlie Parker and Miles Davis, tried to dress and talk like Lena Horne and Cab Calloway. In Sophiatown, gang members modeled themselves after Hollywood movies, dressed in zoot suits, picked up phrases from tough guy films like Street with No Name.
“哈莱姆就像我们的社区，”刘易斯·恩科西说。索菲亚镇的南非黑人听着迪齐·吉莱斯皮、查理·帕克和迈尔斯·戴维斯的音乐，试图模仿莉娜·霍恩和卡布·卡洛韦的穿搭和谈吐。在索菲亚镇，帮派成员模仿好莱坞电影，穿着祖特西装，从《无名街》这类硬汉电影中学习台词。
We wanted to sound like Americans, to relate to American culture. And we wanted also to fantasize about being black Americans rather than black South Africans, because the intensification of suffering in South Africa was just too great. America, it was a country where you have Thurgood Marshall working to eliminate a lot of the civil rights abuses and getting schools integrated and so on. So you know, this was a movement in the opposite direction to where we were moving.
我们想听起来像美国人，想与美国文化产生共鸣。我们也想幻想自己是美国黑人，而不是南非黑人，因为南非所遭受的苦难实在太深重了。美国是一个有瑟古德·马歇尔致力于消除许多民权侵犯、推动学校种族融合的国家。所以你看，这与我们当时的处境正好相反。
Nations, like men, often march to the beat of different drummers. And the precise solutions of the United States can neither be dictated nor transplanted to others. What is important, however, is that all nations must march toward increasing freedom, toward justice for all. You must do this not because it is economically advantageous, although it is, not because the laws of God commanded, although they do, we must do it for the single and fundamental reason that it is the right thing to do.
国家就像人一样，往往各自走着不同的步调。美国的具体解决方案既不能强加给别人，也不能直接移植。然而重要的是，所有国家都必须向着日益增长的自由、向着全民正义迈进。你们必须这样做，不是因为这在经济上有利——尽管确实有利；也不是因为上帝的律法命令这样做——尽管确实如此；我们必须这样做，其根本原因只有一个，那就是这是正确的做法。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And looking to America as a land of hope, this is a cliche now. But we really did believe that.
把美国看作希望之地，这现在已成陈词滥调。但我们当时确实是那么相信的。
Now, of course, the situation is reversed. Once Nelson Mandela got out of prison, and especially after he entered the president's office, it's been black Americans who look to South Africa for inspiration. A few years ago, I did a series of stories for National Public Radio with a South African reporter, comparing race relations in the US with race relations in South Africa. And one of the most striking differences between the way that blacks in the two countries saw things was blacks in South Africa, they said they had hope.
当然，现在情况逆转了。纳尔逊·曼德拉出狱后，特别是在他进入总统办公室后，一直是美国黑人向南非寻求灵感。几年前，我曾与一名南非记者为国家公共广播电台制作了一系列故事，比较美国和南非的种族关系。两国黑人看待事物方式上最显著的区别之一是，南非黑人说他们心怀希望。
Of course, it isn't just black Americans who look to South Africa to see a place where things are changing, where things are getting better in small ways. Today, we've devoted our entire program to the story of two guys who look to South Africa that way. Their names are Josh Seftel and Rich Robinson. Both of them grew up in the normal morass of post-civil rights race relations in this country, went to schools that were integrated but where blacks and whites usually stayed separate, rarely mixed.
当然，不仅仅是美国黑人向南非寻求变化，寻求在小范围内变好的地方。今天，我们将整期节目献给这两个向南非寻求这种感觉的家伙的故事。他们叫乔什·塞夫特尔和里奇·罗宾逊。他们都在这个国家民权运动后种族关系的常态困境中长大，上的学校虽然融合，但黑人和白人通常还是各自分开，很少往来。
So they headed to the new South Africa for a few weeks. And it turns out they did not agree on what they saw there. What we bring you today is partly a story of the emerging multiracial society over there and partly a story about the one here at home to contemplate this 4th of July weekend. Rich starts our story.
于是他们前往了“新南非”待了几周。事实证明，他们对所见所闻意见不合。今天带给大家的这个故事，一部分关于那里正在形成的多元种族社会，另一部分则关于我们国内的种族现状，供大家在这个7月4日周末思考。里奇为我们开启了故事。
It was my idea to go to South Africa. I'd met this South African guy at work. He told me that South Africa is the most beautiful country in the world and that everything you see on TV about it is wrong. I asked Josh to go with me.
去南非是我的主意。我在工作中遇到了一个南非人。他告诉我南非是世界上最美丽的国家，电视上看到的关于它的一切都是错的。我叫乔什跟我一起去。
I had another reason for wanting to visit South Africa. I had just gotten a letter from some South African guy named Benzion Seftel asking if we might be related. My family's very small. Besides my parents and two sisters, there's only a few Seftels in all of North America. I guess I was simultaneously excited and scared. I mean, it's not every day that the size of your family suddenly doubles.
我还有另一个想去南非的理由。我刚收到一个南非人本齐恩·塞夫特尔的来信，问我们是否可能是亲戚。我的家族非常小。除了我父母和两个姐妹，整个北美只有几个塞夫特尔。我当时既兴奋又害怕。毕竟，不是每天都能遇到家族规模突然翻倍的事。
But when they're white South Africans, all these questions pop into your head, the first and most obvious question being, "So do they hate black people?" I mean, what do you do when your family doubles in size but the new half is a bunch of white supremacists? I decided not to share any of these worries with Rich.
但当他们是南非白人时，各种疑问就会涌上心头，第一个最显而易见的疑问就是：“他们恨黑人吗？”我的意思是，当你的家族规模翻倍，但新的一半是一群白人至上主义者，你该怎么办？我决定不把这些担心告诉里奇。
Josh and I met 10 years ago in college. We ended up living in the same house, and we've lived together off and on since then. Josh is the son of a Jewish doctor in the suburbs. I grew up in the city. My parents are public high school teachers. He's white, I'm black, but none of this has ever been an issue. Before this trip, I don't think we ever had one serious talk about race.
乔什和我是10年前在大学认识的。我们最后住进了同一所房子，从那以后断断续续住在一起。乔什是郊区一名犹太医生的儿子。我在城市长大，我父母是公立高中老师。他是白人，我是黑人，但这些从来都不是问题。在这次旅行之前，我不认为我们进行过任何关于种族的严肃谈话。
We both wanted to see the new South Africa, to see how much the country had changed since Nelson Mandela took power two years ago. We decided to begin our search in a neighborhood called Yeoville. The free magazine they give you on the plane had an article about it. Lots of glossy pictures of blacks and whites laughing together in the streets, drinking together in bars and clubs, eating together in restaurants.
我们都想看看新南非，看看自纳尔逊·曼德拉两年前掌权以来这个国家发生了多少变化。我们决定从一个叫耶奥维尔的社区开始我们的探索。飞机上发的免费杂志里有一篇关于它的文章，上面有很多黑人和白人在街上一起欢笑、在酒吧和俱乐部一起喝酒、在餐厅一起吃饭的精美照片。
[CLUB MUSIC]
[俱乐部音乐]
Yeoville's a party. The street is lined with outdoor cafes, people are wearing Nike T-shirts, New York Yankees hats, all kinds of American stuff. The scene is just like the magazine pictures. Blacks and whites talk together and drive by us in BMWs and Mercedes. When Rich and I go into a convenience store to get a drink, there's a tall black man wearing a Public Enemy T-shirt in the corner. He's playing Pac-Man.
耶奥维尔就像一个派对。街道两旁是露天咖啡馆，人们穿着耐克T恤，戴着纽约洋基队的帽子，全是美国货。场景就像杂志图片里一样。黑人和白人交谈着，开着宝马和奔驰车从我们身边经过。当我和里奇走进一家便利店买饮料时，角落里有一个穿着“人民公敌”T恤的高个黑人正在玩吃豆人。
I tell you, things are going properly. We are just mixing up. Like, I'm talking to you guys. I think you are colored, yeah? You are colored?
我告诉你们，事情正在步入正轨。我们正在融合。比如，我正在和你们说话。我想你是“有色人种”，对吧？你是吗？
We call it "black" in America.
在美国，我们称之为“黑人”。
Is it? OK, that's black. And you're "white," right?
是吗？好的，那是黑人。而你是“白人”，对吧？
I'm white.
我是白人。
Yeah, sure, sure, sure. That's OK. I mean, that is positive. You can look like my woman. She has [? got a ?] white too, man.
没错，没问题，那很好。我的意思是，那是积极的。你看，她就像我的女人。伙计，她也是白的。
Standing over by the pay phone, his girlfriend was plump and rosy in an African print jumpsuit and a red cashmere Kangol beret.
站在公用电话旁，他的女朋友穿着一件非洲印花连体裤，戴着一顶红色的开司米康戈尔贝雷帽，显得圆润红润。
She's not from around here, but still, I've got here my woman, my white woman. Lovely. I love her to the maximum, I'll tell you that. But it's like, anyway--
她不是本地人，但总之，我在这里有我的女人，我的白人女人。太棒了。我爱她爱得要死，我告诉你。但总之……
Do think that Yeoville is maybe one of the best places right now because it's mixed?
你认为耶奥维尔现在是最好的地方之一吗，因为它是混合的？
In South Africa?
在南非？
[BEEPING]
[哔哔声]
Sure. Sure.
当然，当然。
What's that?
那是什么？
That's the pager, my man. [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
那是寻呼机，伙计。[听不清]。
What does it say?
上面写什么？
"Talking nonsense." [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
“废话连篇。”[听不清]。
Your girlfriend just paged you from across the room?
你女朋友刚从房间对面给你发了呼叫？
Yeah. She just went to the phone call and paged me, and it's like, hey, beeping! She's-- anyway, guys, hey.
是啊。她刚去打电话给我发了呼叫，就像，嘿，哔哔声！她是——总之，伙计们，嘿。
What's your girlfriend's name?
你女朋友叫什么名字？
Mary.
玛丽。
Mary. If you came into this store five years ago with Mary-- a white woman, black man-- what would have happened?
玛丽。如果五年前你带着玛丽——一个白人女性，一个黑人男性——走进这家店，会发生什么？
I would have been dead eight years ago.
八年前我就死定了。
You would have been dead eight years ago?
八年前你就会死？
That's true.
这是真的。
Why? What would have happened?
为什么？会发生什么？
Yeah. Because I would have been killed by my own brothers because they were fighting against the white people. And if they would have seen me with a white woman, that's the end.
是啊。因为我会死在我自己的兄弟手里，因为他们当时在和白人作斗争。如果他们看到我和一个白人女人在一起，那就是我的终点。
It was our first day in South Africa, and it seemed like everything you'd want it to be, everything you'd dreamed of for the new multiracial society. Blacks and whites together, Pac-man, and personal pagers. We went to the Pita Palace for a celebratory souvlaki, and there, our celebration was cut short.
那是我们在南非的第一天，看起来就像你想要的一切，像你为新的多元种族社会所梦想的一切。黑人和白人在一起，吃豆人，还有个人寻呼机。我们去“皮塔宫”餐厅庆祝，吃了一顿烤肉串，但我们的庆祝活动很快就被打断了。
I'm now 21 years old, right? And what I did was I decided that I have to leave this country.
我今年21岁了，对吧？我所做的决定是，我必须离开这个国家。
Dimitri, the owner of the Pita Palace.
迪米特里，皮塔宫餐厅的老板。
I can't raise my children here. There's too much crime. And they'll just break into your house, take your stuff, and go. They come into your house, they break in, they rape your wife, they shoot you, and totally destroy your life. Kind of like the black people are taking revenge on the whites for apartheid, you know? Someone got around and said, "Oh, let's drive them out of the country." And it's working, because every single year, the emigrations are going up.
我没法在这里养育孩子。犯罪率太高了。他们会闯进你家，抢走你的东西然后跑掉。他们闯进你家，强奸你的妻子，开枪打你，彻底毁了你的生活。就像黑人在为种族隔离对白人进行报复，你知道吗？有人到处说：“哦，把他们赶出这个国家。”这招奏效了，因为移民人数每年都在上升。
A lot of white people are leaving?
很多白人正在离开？
Yeah. Didn't you know that? Thousands, thousands. I know of hundreds of families that have emigrated this year.
是啊。你不知道吗？成千上万。我认识的家庭中，今年就有数百家移居国外。
You're going to leave soon?
你打算很快离开吗？
As soon as I can, yeah.
只要有机会，是的。
Over the next few days, we would hear Dimitri's story over and over. Wherever we went, people talked about crime and fear and whites leaving. That night when we walked home through the dark streets of Johannesburg, we found a shiny bullet shell on the pavement. We took a cab the rest of the way home.
在接下来的几天里，我们反复听到了迪米特里的故事。无论走到哪里，人们都在谈论犯罪、恐惧和白人的离开。那天晚上，当我们走过约翰内斯堡黑暗的街道时，我们在人行道上发现了一颗闪亮的子弹壳。剩下回家的路，我们打了一辆出租车。
[RUNNING WATER]
[流水声]
You excited?
你兴奋吗？
About what?
关于什么？
What are you doing today?
你今天打算做什么？
Going to see--
去见……
[ELECTRIC RAZOR]
[电动剃须刀声]
--the people that I think are my relatives. That's why I'm shaving.
……我认为是我的亲戚的人。这就是为什么我在刮胡子。
So how many times have you talked to them?
那你和他们通过几次电话？
Well, I've talked to them on the phone once-- twice.
嗯，我在电话里跟他们谈过一次……两次。
Do you think they're shaving right now too?
你觉得他们现在也在刮胡子吗？
I can only hope so.
我只能希望如此。
Are you nervous?
你紧张吗？
Not really. I mean, it could be interesting.
并不真的。我的意思是，这可能会很有趣。
Well, what if you don't impress them?
嗯，如果你不能给他们留下好印象怎么办？
I'm just afraid that they're going to be racist and they're going to hate you because you're black, and that you'd never forgive me for it.
我只是怕他们会种族歧视，会因为你是黑人而讨厌你，而你永远不会原谅我。
So you're going to have a little anxious energy?
所以你会有一些焦虑的情绪？
Perhaps.
也许吧。
We Seftels are unusual.
我们塞夫特尔家的人很不寻常。
Well, look at Joshua, you see.
嗯，你看乔舒亚，你瞧。
Yeah. And we've got many stories. Well, I suppose Harold told you-- I don't want to go over it-- his association with Mandela. Did he tell you?
是啊。我们有很多故事。嗯，我想哈罗德告诉你了——我不想再复述一遍——他与曼德拉的交往。他告诉你了吗？
So here we are with my long-lost family. Sitting around a big table piled with lasagna and fresh baked bread, are Harold Seftel, his sisters Dolly and Molly Seftel, Dolly's son Louis, and Rich and I. They reminded me of my relatives back is Schenectady.
所以我们现在和我失散多年的家人在一起。桌上堆满了千层面和新鲜出炉的面包，围坐在桌旁的是哈罗德·塞夫特尔，他的姐妹多莉和莫莉·塞夫特尔，多莉的儿子路易斯，以及里奇和我。他们让我想起了我在斯克内克塔迪的亲戚。
Josh looks a lot like Louis. It was easy to believe they were related. Nevertheless, we spent several long hours around dinner trying to prove it.
乔什长得很像路易斯。很容易相信他们是有亲缘关系的。尽管如此，我们还是在晚餐桌上花了好几个小时试图证明这一点。
Now, Uncle Borach is which person here?
现在，伯拉赫叔叔是这里的哪位？
Now, that's my father Louie.
那个是我父亲路易。
That's Louie, the little boy in the picture?
那是路易，照片里的小男孩？
That's right. Yes.
没错。是的。
And then Uncle Borach is him?
那伯拉赫叔叔是他？
They pulled out some old photos, including that turn-of-the-century photograph that every Jewish family has. It's black and white, ragged at the edges, with a neatly posed family. The father in this picture had a thick, white beard, heavy eyelids, and a black-brimmed hat. He was probably my great uncle.
他们拿出了一些老照片，包括每家犹太家庭都有的那种世纪之交的照片。那是黑白的，边缘破损，一家人整齐地站着。照片里的父亲留着浓密的白胡子，眼皮厚重，戴着一顶黑色宽边帽。他可能是我叔祖父。
Yes, well, he was very smart. Apparently, he was a ladies' man.
是的，他非常聪明。显然，他还是个花花公子。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yes. He had lots of ladies. In fact--
是的，他有很多相好的。事实上……
There's something about meeting distant relatives so far from home. There's this immediate bond that's basic and powerful, this feeling like you're all players on the same team, even though you've just met. But at the same time, mainly because Rich was there with me, I was nervous and wanted to know what the people around the dinner table had done during apartheid.
在离家这么远的地方见到远房亲戚总有种奇妙的感觉。有一种即时的联系，既基础又强大，感觉你们就像是同一队球员，尽管才刚见面。但与此同时，主要是因为里奇和我在一起，我很紧张，想知道餐桌旁的人在种族隔离时期做了什么。
It's embarrassing to think about now, but I asked them repeatedly to talk about those years. At first, they were reluctant to discuss it, but finally they did. I was relieved to find out that Harold, a tall, lean, 60-year-old with squinty eyes, not only knows Nelson Mandela, he's one of his doctors. After Mandela came out of prison, he invited Harold and his kids for lunch. During apartheid, Molly was active in a group called The Black Sash, which picketed outside the court buildings.
现在想起来很尴尬，但我反复请求他们谈谈那些年。起初，他们不愿讨论，但最终还是说了。我很高兴发现哈罗德，一个60岁、眼睛眯缝的高瘦男人，不仅认识纳尔逊·曼德拉，还是他的医生之一。曼德拉出狱后，邀请了哈罗德和他的孩子们去吃午餐。在种族隔离时期，莫莉是一个名为“黑带”组织的活跃成员，该组织在法院大楼外进行纠察。
At the end of the day, what did we do? I mean, it's not that we rioted in the streets or that we--
说到底，我们做了什么？我的意思是，我们并没有在街上暴乱，也没有……
But I mean, look at you. You only worked in black hospitals, you wouldn't--
但我的意思是，看看你。你只在黑人医院工作，你不会……
I would not-- I worked in a black hospital. And look, I suppose I did a little bit of good--
我不会……我在黑人医院工作。你看，我想我做了一点好事……
I mean, you changed the attitude of students towards black people. And he was--
我的意思是，你改变了学生对黑人的态度。而且他当时……
But I can't really describe myself as an activist. Let's be honest.
但我不能真的形容自己是活动家。咱们说实话。
Yeah, but your daughter was an activist.
是啊，但你女儿是活动家。
Yes, but my children. I think I would say my children.
是的，但我的孩子们。我想我会说我的孩子们。
It turns out, Harold's son David used to drive around giving medical care to black activists who were too scared to go into the state hospitals. Harold's daughter Lisa is a member of Mandela's party, the ANC. She was arrested and imprisoned for several months during the struggle and had to go into hiding underground for years. For a while, Lisa's Aunt Dolly and Dolly's son Louis, who are less political, let her stay at their house.
事实证明，哈罗德的儿子大卫过去常开车为那些不敢去国立医院的黑人活动家提供医疗服务。哈罗德的女儿莉萨是曼德拉政党非国大的成员。她在斗争期间被逮捕并监禁了几个月，不得不隐藏在地下生活了好几年。有一段时间，莉萨的姑妈多莉和多莉的儿子路易斯，政治色彩没那么浓，让她待在他们家。
Yes, '86, when we went to Israel, that's when she stayed and moved in here with the ANC.
是的，86年我们去以色列的时候，那就是她留下来和非国大搬进来的时候。
That's a great story. During that year, because she needed a place to hide, we said that she could stay here and she could run whatever she wants to here. Because it was safe, it was suburbia, it wasn't where the activists hang out in Yeoville. So this was a great cover for her. So she stretched out and she spread out by the pool. All the ANC communists just laid out by the pool.
那是段伟大的故事。那一年，因为她需要一个藏身之处，我们说她可以住在这里，可以在这里做她想做的任何事。因为这里很安全，这里是郊区，不是活动家常待的耶奥维尔。所以这对她来说是个极好的掩护。所以她就在泳池边伸展身体，到处休息。所有的非国大共产主义者都躺在泳池边。
We don't know that, Louis.
路易斯，我们不知道那点。
We know from Joseph, our servant. He's from Malau. He has worked for us for 35 years. And Joseph would tell us that every day he would cook for them. And he would bring them meals. And he would serve them as they were writing their newsletters and their propaganda.
我们从我们的仆人约瑟夫那里知道的。他来自马拉维。他为我们工作了35年。约瑟夫会告诉我们，他每天都给他们做饭，给他们送餐。他像服务他们一样服务他们，而他们则在那里写着通讯和宣传资料。
Even though Louis seemed to have some problems with the ANC, Harold knew Mandela, Lisa was in the ANC, Molly was protesting in the streets. As far as I was concerned, my family passed the test. My fear that they would be a bunch of white supremacists was put to rest and I felt relieved.
尽管路易斯似乎对非国大有些看法，但哈罗德认识曼德拉，莉萨在非国大，莫莉在街头抗议。就我而言，我的家人通过了考验。我担心他们会是一群白人至上主义者的担忧消除了，我感到如释重负。
I felt uncomfortable. Dolly and Louis got this nervous, self-congratulatory tone when they talked to me  about some of this stuff.
我感到很不舒服。当多莉和路易斯跟我谈论其中一些事情时，他们那种紧张的、沾沾自喜的语气让我很不爽。
And we're very unique. First of all, we're one of the few white families that's got a black child in the family. I mean, I'm the aunt of this-- and not many Jewish families have got black children. In fact, I don't think there are any other Jewish families. And there's one family, but they adopted the black child.
而且我们非常独特。首先，我们是为数不多的家族里有黑人孩子的白人家庭之一。我的意思是，我是这个……的姑妈，而且没有多少犹太家庭有黑人孩子。事实上，我不认为有其他犹太家庭。只有一个家庭，但他们是领养的黑人孩子。
It was just one of those situations where you never forget you're the only black person in the room. After eating, Louis took us on a short tour of their estate. We saw their expensive bedrooms, pools, Jacuzzis, and finally, tucked around the back of the house, was the servants' quarters, which consisted of a tiny main room with four beds and a closet-sized bathroom. One worker was in the room at the time watching a dim black-and-white TV. Beside his head on the wall was a photocopy of a game board.
那简直就是那种你永远不会忘记自己是房间里唯一的黑人的情况之一。吃完饭后，路易斯带我们参观了他们的庄园。我们看到了他们昂贵的卧室、游泳池、按摩浴缸，最后，藏在房子后面的，是仆人宿舍，由一个带有四张床的微小主房间和一个衣柜大小的浴室组成。当时有一个工人在房间里看着一台昏暗的黑白电视。他头边的墙上贴着一张游戏板的复印件。
Louis told us that this was a lottery game. If you picked the right square, you won the pot for that week. I asked him who played. He pointed to the servant and said in a patronizing tone, that all of "them" do. The servant shook his head to say that he did not play, but Louis repeated that "all blacks played."
路易斯告诉我们这是一个彩票游戏。如果你选对了方格，就能赢得那一周的奖池。我问他谁玩这个。他指了指那个仆人，用一种居高临下的语气说，“他们”所有人都会玩。那个仆人摇了摇头表示他没玩，但路易斯重复说“所有黑人都玩”。
Later, there was this awkward moment-- awkward for me, anyway-- when Dolly and Louis were talking about Harold's daughter, Lisa.
后来，出现了一个尴尬时刻——至少对我来说很尴尬——当时多莉和路易斯正在谈论哈罗德的女儿莉萨。
Her main boyfriends were black.
她的主要男朋友都是黑人。
But she would always say that the blacks in the ANC were always--
但她总是说非国大的黑人总是……
But that was the-- often you won't find, she doesn't criticize much, but she did say that the blacks, the boyfriends were not faithful. They had lots of women. And even the man that she's had the baby with, he's got a child. But I hope that he's faithful to her.
但那就是——通常你不会发现，她不怎么批评，但她确实说过那些黑人，那些男朋友不忠诚。他们有很多女人。甚至她为之生下孩子的那个男人，他也有个孩子。但我希望他对她忠诚。
Well, I don't know how she meant it, but that sweeping statement about what all blacks are like, all blacks are unfaithful, that did it for me. That let me know who they were.
嗯，我不知道她是什么意思，但那句关于所有黑人都是什么样、所有黑人都不忠诚的概括性言论，让我彻底受够了。那让我知道了他们是什么样的人。
I'm saying I went over to that family and I felt tension because of a reason. That's what I'm saying.
我是说我去了那个家庭，我感到了紧张，是有原因的。这就是我想说的。
I don't know. I don't quite understand what was tangibly so harsh about--
我不知道。我不太明白关于……有什么本质上那么刺耳的地方。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
Back at the hotel, we talked about dinner.
回到酒店，我们讨论了晚餐。
It's just the first time that I had seen white settlers talking about blacks and their domestic help and who they keep around. And it was just I didn't realize how even the most liberal whites aren't necessarily the most-- they're proud that they have Lisa in their family because that way they can say that they are, in fact, the most liberal whites.
这是我第一次看到白人定居者谈论黑人、谈论他们的家庭佣工和他们留在身边的人。我只是没意识到即使是最开明的白人也未必是最……他们为家里有莉萨感到自豪，因为这样他们就可以说自己实际上是最开明的白人。
It's almost like you don't want to like them.
简直就像你不想喜欢他们一样。
Pfft. I'm serious. I did not go in there not wanting to like them. But I definitely felt tense. And I didn't know why I felt tense. And I started to feel bad, and I started not wanting to be there. You missed it, though. When you left the room and it was just all of us in the room, we had nothing to talk about. They didn't want to talk to me at all. I mean, there was noticeable silence, and there was nothing going on.
呸。我是认真的。我绝不是带着不喜欢他们的念头去的。但我确实感到了紧张。我不知道为什么会紧张。我开始感到难受，开始不想待在那里。不过你错过了，当你离开房间，只剩下我们几个的时候，我们根本没什么可聊的。他们根本不想跟我说话。我的意思是，沉默是显而易见的，什么事也没发生。
You honestly believe that most white South African families are more liberal or as liberal as them?
你真的相信大多数南非白人家庭比他们更开明，或者和他们一样开明吗？
No! See, I didn't say that. I said exactly what I said. I went and I saw and that was the reality and I felt, and that's what happened to me. Period.
不！你看，我没那么说。我说的就是我说的话。我去了，我看到了，那是事实，我感觉到了，这就是发生在我身上的事。句号。
I'm not taking that away from you.
我不是在剥夺你的感受。
OK.
好吧。
You want to fight more? Hm?
你想再吵架吗？嗯？
I can't fight about what I feel.
我没法为了我的感觉而吵架。
I guess I'm saying that-- I don't know. I mean, I was pleasantly surprised that they were less racist than I could ever have expected.
我想说的是……我不知道。我的意思是，我惊喜地发现他们比我预想的种族歧视程度要轻。
Well, did you hear what I'm saying? You're saying that because they were less racist than we thought they were going to be, that's good. And yes, that is good. But I'm still allowed to be upset about it. And I am, in fact, upset about it.
嗯，你听到我说的了吗？你说因为他们比我们预想的种族歧视程度轻，所以这很好。是的，那确实很好。但我仍然有权为此感到难过。而且事实上，我确实为此感到难过。
And you know what it's like? It's exactly like America. There's an underlying tension, and people want to be friends and all of that. But on the underside, they're all just [BLEEP] dicks.
你知道这像什么吗？这就像美国一样。有一种潜藏的紧张感，人们想做朋友，诸如此类。但在底层，他们其实都是[消音]混蛋。
This is where we live. This is our milieu. There's a wonderful park here.
这是我们生活的地方。这是我们的环境。这里有一个很棒的公园。
Rich needed a break from my family. So when Molly came to pick us up for breakfast, I went alone. She gave me a driving tour of the neighborhood.
里奇需要从我的家人那里休息一下。所以当莫莉来接我们吃早餐时，我一个人去了。她带我开车游览了这个社区。
OK, now in this house-- let me show you-- in this house, this lady was attacked. They jumped over that fence and beat her up. I'll show you where another person was murdered.
好的，现在在这座房子里——让我给你看——在这座房子里，这位女士遭到了袭击。他们跳过那道栅栏，把她打了一顿。我会告诉你另一个人是在哪里被谋杀的。
We drove through peaceful, leafy neighborhoods with big houses. But almost every house was surrounded by a high fence and barbed wire. One neighborhood had a manned checkpoint to keep people out who didn't belong. Another had armed security guards patrolling the tree-lined streets on bicycle. We drove past an area that looked like a golf course with a neatly manicured lawn. And right by the curb, half-hidden by the shrubbery, were maybe half a dozen black people, sitting and laying on the ground.
我们开车穿过安静、绿树成荫的社区和巨大的房子。但几乎每一栋房子周围都环绕着高高的栅栏和铁丝网。一个社区设有带警卫的检查站，把不属于那里的人挡在外面。另一个社区有全副武装的保安在树荫街道上骑自行车巡逻。我们经过一片看起来像高尔夫球场、草坪修剪整齐的区域。就在路边，被灌木丛遮住了一半，大概有六个黑人坐在或躺在地上。
In this bush here, the people squat. Anywhere where there's water, the homeless squat.
在这灌木丛里，人们私自居住。任何有水的地方，无家可归者就会在那里扎营。
That's amazing, because this looks like a very well-off neighborhood, and right on the edge, there are squatters.
这太惊人了，因为这看起来是个非常富裕的社区，而就在边缘，却有非法居住者。
When my daughter Louise was here, there was a ring at our intercom. And I looked through the window, and I said "There's one of these squatters." I said, "Don't open the door." She says, "Tsk, Mommy."
我女儿路易丝在这里时，对讲机响了。我透过窗户一看，说：“那是那些非法居住者之一。”我说：“别开门。”她说：“啧，妈妈。”
So she said, "Yes?" He said, "Please Madam, please. I want some bread." So I said, "Don't give it to him because he'll send hundreds here. And your mother will be killed. And leave him alone. He'll go and tell the others. You don't give him anything!" So I had just baked  some bread, I made sandwiches. And I said, "Louise, I'm warning you. You'll find your mother dead."
所以她说：“什么事？”他说：“请太太，请，我想要点面包。”所以我说：“别给他，因为他会引来数百个过来。你会被杀的，让他走吧。他会去告诉别人的。什么也别给他！”但我刚烤了一些面包，做了三明治。我说：“路易丝，我警告你。你会发现你妈妈死掉的。”
But she went on, and she put lettuce and tomatoes and cheese. And I said, "Louise, he's going to tell all the others. And you'll see. It'll be terrible. Leave it. Don't do it. Don't do it." And she walks up to the gate, and he says, "Oh, Madam! God bless you." And she said, "And don't you ever dare come here again!" And he jumped back. And do you know what? The next day they were ringing again.
但她还是去了，放了生菜、西红柿和奶酪。我说：“路易丝，他会去告诉所有其他人的。你会看到的，那会很可怕。别做了。别做了。”她走到大门口，他说：“噢，太太！上帝保佑你。”她说：“你永远别想再来这里了！”他跳开了。你猜怎么着？第二天他们又在按门铃了。
We were back at her house. She pulled her car up to the big gates and punched in a code. Metal doors slowly parted and we drove in.
我们回到她家。她把车开到大门前，输入了一个密码。金属门缓缓拉开，我们开了进去。
And you know how we used to live before? We had no fence. Nobody had fences.
你知道我们以前怎么生活的吗？我们没有栅栏。没人有栅栏。
Crime has gotten worse since the end of apartheid, but it's not as big an increase as most people think. Since 1994, the murder has actually dropped 14%. Car thefts have dropped. Home burglaries have increased only 11%. The biggest increase in crime is non-residential robberies, which is up 50%, and rape, which is up 36%. What's happening is that crime in the white areas is now becoming the same as it's always been in the black townships.
种族隔离结束后犯罪确实变严重了，但并没有大多数人认为的那样增长巨大。自1994年以来，谋杀案实际上下降了14%。汽车盗窃案有所下降。入室盗窃案仅增加了11%。犯罪增长最快的是非住宅抢劫，上升了50%，强奸案上升了36%。发生的情况是，白人地区的犯罪现在变得和黑人居住区一直以来的情况一样了。
Josh and I weren't getting along so well since the fight in the hotel room. In the 10 years we have known each other, we had never really fought before. So we decided the best thing for our friendship would be to get away from his family and out of Johannesburg.
自酒店房间那次争吵后，我和里奇相处得不太好。我们认识的10年里，从未真正吵过架。所以我们认为为了友谊，最好的办法是离开他的家人，走出约翰内斯堡。
We rented a tiny Volkswagen and set out to see more of the new South Africa. We drove for hours over green, rolling hills. The deeper we got into the country, the fewer and fewer white faces we saw. Every so often, we'd see a cluster of pink and aquamarine huts on a hillside, a village. Finally, we stopped at one.
我们租了一辆小众的大众汽车，出发去看看更多的新南非。我们在绿色的连绵起伏的山丘上开了几个小时的车。我们越往深处走，看到的白人面孔就越少。每隔一段时间，我们就会看到山坡上一簇簇粉色和海蓝色的棚屋，那是村庄。最后，我们在其中一个村庄停了下来。
There's a group of guys about our age sitting in an old car seat next to one of the huts. They looked like they were waiting for something to happen. They didn't seem happy with the new South Africa.
有一群和我们年纪差不多的人坐在其中一个棚屋旁的一个旧汽车座椅上。他们看起来像是在等待什么事情发生。他们似乎对新南非并不满意。
They promised us money. They promised us jobs. There's nothing that ever have happened like that.
他们承诺给我们钱，承诺给我们工作。那种事从来都没发生过。
All three men were unemployed. For Wayne, a tall, thin man who covered his shaved head with a black fedora, told us that the new government had finally brought electricity to the village just that week.
三个人全都失业了。韦恩，一个高高瘦瘦的男人，头上戴着一顶黑色软呢帽，告诉我们新政府直到那周才最终给村里通了电。
They bring us electricity first. Why not water first? Why didn't they ask us "What thing do you want first?" Are we going to eat electricity? Are we going to drink electricity? Where are we going to get money to buy this electricity if we are not employed?
他们先给我们通电。为什么不先供水？为什么他们不问我们“你们最想要什么？”我们要吃电吗？我们要喝电吗？如果我们没有工作，我们哪来的钱买这些电？
They invited us into their shebeen for beers. They asked us questions about America, about our girlfriends, about the federal system, how we liked people at the office. They told us a story about why black men's noses are flat and white men's noses are long. They asked me if I was a relative of Michael Jackson. And they complained about the new South Africa. Wayne said if he were president, he'd enact a much more radical redistribution than Nelson Mandela has.
他们邀请我们去他们的酒馆喝啤酒。他们问我们关于美国的问题，关于我们的女朋友，关于联邦制度，我们怎么看待办公室里的人。他们给我们讲了一个关于为什么黑人的鼻子是扁的，白人的鼻子是长的故事。他们问我是不是迈克尔·杰克逊的亲戚。他们抱怨新南非。韦恩说如果他是总统，他会制定比纳尔逊·曼德拉更激进的财富再分配政策。
What I should do-- all those white men's area, white men's toilet, I'll do it upside-down. If this was the black man's toilet, then that is the white man's toilet. I'll take the whites there and tell them to come here in black men's toilets and then I'll write "Whites only." Yeah? The only thing maybe that should be the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我该做的——那些白人的区域，白人的厕所，我会把它颠倒过来。如果那是黑人的厕所，那这就是白人的厕所。我会把白人带到那里，告诉他们去黑人的厕所，然后我会写上“仅限白人”。是啊？唯一可能应该是[听不清]。
But doesn't hatred breed more hatred?
但仇恨不是会滋生更多的仇恨吗？
It's in the blood now. It's in the blood.
它现在已经在血液里了。它已经在血液里了。
Sitting in the shebeen, Josh and I were more relaxed with each other. There's nothing like a little talk about apartheid to make you forget your personal problems.
坐在酒馆里，乔什和我彼此放松了一些。没有什么比谈论种族隔离更能让你忘记个人烦恼的了。
One of the guys had an old accordion out on the car seat. I asked him to play a song and he did. "A Roman hymn," he told us.
其中一个人在汽车座椅上放了一架旧手风琴。我让他演奏一首歌曲，他照做了。“一首罗马赞美诗，”他告诉我们。
For these guys, the new South Africa was a lot like the old South Africa. They were still without water and work, and they still felt powerless. Apartheid had done more than just separate the races. It had created a lasting sense of black inferiority.
对这些人来说，新南非和旧南非没什么两样。他们仍然没有水和工作，仍然感到无力。种族隔离所做的不仅仅是隔离种族，它还制造了一种持久的黑人自卑感。
The blacks, if they see a small boy of white meat, they think that small boy of white meat is-- I forgot-- is bigger than them. And they've got money, and they've got whatever. We always see ourselves as inferior as [? what we ?] [? have told, ?] the doctor and the system of [? his. ?] That thing will not end.
黑人们，如果他们看到一个白人的小男孩，他们觉得那个白人小男孩……我忘了……比他们大。他们有钱，他们拥有一切。我们总是把自我看得低人一等，就像……医生和他的系统所告诉我们的那样。那件事永远不会结束。
On the way out of the village, we ran into three teenage village girls. One of them wore a thick layer of white face paint, like a mask. She said it was for pimples. We were talking, and they were teaching us how to say hello in Xhosa. And then the girl with face paint turned and looked us over. She looked at Rich's skin, which was a few shades later than her own. Then see looked at mine, which was a few shades lighter still. Then she looked at both of us. "Are you brothers?" She asked us.
离开村庄的路上，我们遇到了三个村里的少女。其中一个涂着厚厚的白色面粉，像个面具。她说那是为了遮痘痘。我们正聊着，她们教我们怎么用科萨语说你好。然后那个涂着粉的女孩转过身打量我们。她看了看里奇的皮肤，那比她自己的浅几度。然后看了看我的，比她的还要再浅几度。然后她看了看我们俩。“你们是兄弟吗？”她问我们。
Our trip to South Africa continues with the South African Woodstock and an organization that's half Nancy Reagan's "Just Say No" and half terrorist group. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
我们对南非的旅行将继续，内容包括南非的“伍德斯托克”音乐节，以及一个半像南希·里根“向毒品说不”的口号、半像恐怖组织的组织。稍后继续，来自国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Usually we bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. But today, we're devoting our whole show to just one story about South Africa's emerging multiracial society and about America's.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题。通常我们会给您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。但今天，我们将整个节目献给仅仅一个关于南非新兴多元种族社会以及关于美国的单一故事。
If you just tuned in, Rich Robinson and Josh Seftel are best friends. One's black, one's white. Rich is a New Yorker. Josh is from Boston. They traveled together to the new South Africa not long after Nelson Mandela took the president's office to meet some people who Josh thinks might be distant relatives of his and to see what's changed since Nelson Mandela began his experiment at creating a multiracial society, and what hasn't changed.
如果您刚调频过来，里奇·罗宾逊和乔什·塞夫特尔是最好的朋友。一个是黑人，一个是白人。里奇是纽约人，乔什来自波士顿。他们在纳尔逊·曼德拉就职总统后不久前往新南非，去见一些乔什认为是自己远房亲戚的人，看看自曼德拉开始创造多元种族社会实验以来发生了什么变化，以及什么没发生变化。
Say "Boer."
说“布尔”。
Boer.
布尔。
Say it.
说出来。
Boer. I am a Boer.
布尔。我是一个布尔人。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
That means I don't like you.
意思是说我不喜欢你。
Boers are the descendants of Dutch settlers in South Africa. And the stereotype is they're farmers, they're racists, they're African rednecks. They're the group of whites who actually voted for apartheid and built the apartheid state. And Rich had become obsessed with them. Every white person was suspect, especially in the countryside.
布尔人是南非荷兰定居者的后裔。刻板印象是他们是农民，是种族主义者，是非洲的乡巴佬。他们是那群真正投票支持种族隔离、建立种族隔离国家的白人。而里奇已经对他们着了迷。每一个白人都值得怀疑，尤其是在农村地区。
Do you think we've seen a lot of Boers?
你认为我们见到了很多布尔人吗？
Actually, yeah, we have. On dirt roads, the dudes driving cars with the buzz cuts and crazy-looking eyes, tanned skin. Don't you think those are Boers? Don't you think they look like that? The little buzz-cut guy?
其实，是见到了。在土路上，那些开着车、留着平头、眼神疯狂、皮肤黝黑的家伙。你不觉得那是布尔人吗？你不觉得他们长那样吗？那个平头小个子？
I guess I don't-- I'm not looking for Boers. I only notice it when you say it.
我猜我没有……我没有在找布尔人。只有当你这么说时我才注意到。
The fact is, I came to South Africa hoping to confront real racists. In America now, racism is like this cloud that's still surrounding us, but you can't touch it or see it. You just feel it when you go to a party or when you go into a store. But in South Africa, white oppression officially just ended two years ago. I came here thinking it would be like seeing what it was like during the bus boycotts in the '60s or during the Civil War. I came here looking for the enemy.
事实是，我来南非是希望与真正的种族主义者对峙。在美国，种族主义现在就像围绕着我们的云雾，你摸不到也看不见。你只有在参加派对或走进商店时才能感觉到。但在南非，白人压迫仅仅在两年前才正式结束。我来到这里，认为这会像是在60年代公共汽车抵制运动期间或内战期间。我是来寻找敌人的。
Which didn't bother me, as long as Rich wasn't looking for my family to be that enemy.
这对我没影响，只要里奇不把我的家人视为那个敌人就行。
Boer.
布尔。
That's good. That's good.
很好。很好。
Boer. I can't do it.
布尔。我做不到。
Do Boer.
做布尔。
Boer. Boer.
布尔。布尔。
We had read about a place called Rustler's Valley in our guidebook. It said that Rustler's was one of the most progressive places in the country, maybe on the continent, a kind of ongoing South African Woodstock. When we got there, there were lots of hippie-looking people with long beards, toting aboriginal instruments and bongos. The horticulture there looked like something out of a Dr. Seuss book. On one hillside, it looked like someone was holding a VW van convention. On another hillside, we joined a group of people who were in the middle of experiencing "a sound journey."
我们在旅游指南上读到一个叫“盗贼山谷”的地方。上面说那是全国、甚至可能是全非洲最进步的地方之一，一种持续不断的南非“伍德斯托克”。当我们到达那里时，有很多看起来像嬉皮士的人，留着长胡子，随身带着原住民乐器和邦戈鼓。那里的园艺看起来像是苏斯博士书里的东西。在一个山坡上，看起来像是在开大众面包车会议。在另一个山坡上，我们加入了一群正在体验“声音之旅”的人。
They all sat in a circle with their eyes closed and their legs crossed. In the middle of the circle was a man with a bunch of instruments. He was blowing on a didgeridoo. When he stopped, they went around the circle talking about how the sound journey had made them feel.
他们全都围成一个圆圈，闭着眼睛，盘腿坐着。圆圈中间是一个带着一堆乐器的男人。他正在吹迪吉里杜管。当他停下来时，他们围着圆圈交谈，讲述“声音之旅”给他们的感受。
It was an amazing experience. I actually still feel quite out of my body, really. And thank you for creating the space to help me let go. I'm just feeling incredibly emotional.
那是一次令人惊叹的体验。我实际上仍然感到我的灵魂脱离了肉体。感谢你创造了这个空间来帮助我释放。我感到无比激动。
I experienced such a movement through, I don't know if it was my bloodstream or my soul.
我经历了一次灵魂的洗礼，不知道是血液里还是灵魂深处。
Down by the river, it was like Eden. There were people swimming naked and horses drinking from water and running wild. A group of two women and two men were passing around reefers the size of small cigars. But most of the action at Rustler's took place around a giant, flaming globe. At night, hundreds of kids danced to techno music in the firelight. Next to the dance floor was a pool where nude swimming was encouraged. There was a room called The Passion Pit, with low couches, dim lighting, and intertwined bodies. There was the tepee village. Rich and I went down there and ran into this guy wearing moccasins, knickers, and a feather headdress. He rolled a joint and talked to us about Rustler's philosophy.
在河边，简直就像伊甸园。有人赤身裸体游泳，马儿在水边喝水，自由奔跑。两男两女的一群人正在传递着像小雪茄一样大的大麻烟。但盗贼山谷的大部分活动发生在巨大的、燃烧的地球仪周围。夜晚，成百上千的孩子在火光中随着高科技音乐跳舞。舞池旁边是一个鼓励裸泳的泳池。有一个叫“激情坑”的房间，里面有矮沙发、昏暗的灯光和交织在一起的身体。还有帐篷村。里奇和我走过去，遇到了一个穿着鹿皮鞋、马裤和羽毛头饰的家伙。他卷了一根大麻烟，跟我们谈论起盗贼山谷的哲学。
I very much believe that psychedelics have been around since the beginning of time. They've aided in man's evolution. And I think they can take us towards the future, certainly in dissolving personal boundaries and ideals of who we are and what we are and who we are about. So smoke a lot of dope.
我非常相信致幻剂自古以来就存在。它们辅助了人类的进化。我认为它们能引导我们走向未来，肯定是在消除个人界限以及关于我们是谁、我们是什么以及我们代表什么的理想方面。所以，多吸点大麻。
A lot of people in our government are smokers. They were left-wing revolutionaries and radicals. I've personally had conversations with this deputy staff president about hemp and the role it will play in regenerating rural economies.
我们政府里的许多人都是吸食者。他们曾是左翼革命者和激进分子。我个人曾与这位副总统幕僚长谈过关于大麻及其在振兴农村经济中将扮演的角色。
We had somehow wandered into a techno version of America in the '60s. But if America's '60s were about rebellion, it wasn't clear from anyone we talked to who or what, exactly, Rustler's meant to be rebelling against. In the smoky bar near the dance floor, we met the founder of Rustler's. He's 40-something with a pony tail, beard, and an African wrap that covered his hairy legs to the knees. His name was Frick. He explained the enemy.
我们不知怎么误入了一个60年代美国的科技版。但如果说60年代的美国是关于反叛，那从我们谈过的任何人那里，都不清楚盗贼山谷究竟意味着反叛谁或什么。在舞池附近的烟雾缭绕的酒吧里，我们遇到了盗贼山谷的创始人。他40多岁，留着马尾辫、胡子，身上围着一块遮住毛腿到膝盖的非洲围裙。他叫弗里克。他解释了敌人是谁。
You see, the power structure that we're rebelling against is the American government. We see them misleading the whole world down a corporate dead end into neomodernism. They're leaving no space for society to develop. We believe we need to return to Shamanism or return to magic or return to values of the earth, an understanding that was held by most ethnic people. So we see our source of inspiration as being the ethnic peoples that the corporate world hasn't yet [BLEEP] up.
你看，我们反叛的权力结构是美国政府。我们看到他们误导全世界走向一个企业死胡同，进入一种新现代主义。他们没有给社会留下发展的空间。我们认为我们需要回归萨满教，或回归魔法，或回归地球的价值观，这些理解被大多数少数民族所持有。所以我们将我们的灵感来源视为那些企业世界尚未[消音]搞砸的少数民族。
So the American government was the enemy, and the solution was the ethnic peoples. The only problem was, there were no ethnic peoples there. In a country made up of Zulus, Ndebele, Sotho, and Xhosa, a country with 12 official native languages, besides the kitchen workers and occasional gardener, I was the only black person at Rustler's. Josh and I did a little informal survey. Why no black people?
所以美国政府是敌人，解决方案是少数民族。唯一的问题是，那里没有少数民族。在一个由祖鲁人、恩德贝莱人、索托人和科萨人组成的国家，一个除了厨工和偶尔出现的园丁外拥有12种官方原住民语言的国家，我是盗贼山谷里唯一的黑人。乔什和我做了一个小小的非正式调查。为什么没有黑人？
It's anyone. Whoever wants to come can come. And maybe black people just aren't into it, you know?
每个人都行。无论谁想来都可以来。也许黑人只是不喜欢这些，你知道吗？
There is plenty. They come up here to work and clean and do the gardens.
这里有很多。他们来这里工作、打扫卫生、打理花园。
They're not into the same thing we're into. Black people don't like raves and rave parties and I don't see that as a bad thing.
他们对我们感兴趣的东西不感兴趣。黑人不喜欢狂欢派对，我不认为那是什么坏事。
We have a very good rapport with them. When we go to town, they all wave at us. And they're friendly.
我们和他们关系很好。当我们进城时，他们都向我们招手，很友好。
Apartheid takes a lot of time to dissolve. And even if you want to cross the barriers, they're not that easily crossed because they've always been separate. It's a pity.
种族隔离需要很长时间才能消解。即使你想跨越壁垒，它们也不是那么容易跨越的，因为它们一直都是分开的。真可惜。
Rustler's Valley wasn't really a part of the new South Africa. It was more like a theme park for recreational drug users, a summer camp escape for young, white South Africans where they didn't have to think about the crime rates or the futures in this country. After two hazy days, when we finally got back into our room, we found a young, blond-haired woman sprawled across one of our beds rolling a joint in the bedspread. It was 5:00 in the morning. We'd had enough. We asked her to leave.
盗贼山谷并不是真正新南非的一部分。它更像是一个娱乐性吸毒者的主题公园，是年轻南非白人的暑期营地逃避所，在那里他们不必思考这个国家的犯罪率或未来。在两天朦朦胧胧的生活后，当我们终于回到房间时，发现一个年轻的金发女人躺在我们床上，在床罩上卷着大麻烟。当时是凌晨5点。我们受够了。我们让她离开。
Back in the States, I almost never notice race. But since I'd been in South Africa, I found myself noticing it whenever Rich and I walked into a room. I'd look around and think, are there any black people here? I worried he'd be uncomfortable.
回到美国，我几乎从不注意种族。但在南非，我发现无论里奇和我走进哪个房间，我都会注意到种族。我会环顾四周想，这里有黑人吗？我担心他不舒服。
Do you feel like they're treating you differently than they're treating me as a white person?
你觉得他们对待你和对待我这个白人有什么不同吗？
Oh, yeah. Sure. Don't you think?
哦，是的。当然。你不觉得吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
It's that expectation. I walked in the main room. They had a couple people behind the desk. And two or three people were hanging out. And they were having at least two conversations, possibly three. You know, different groups of people. Not many people, six to eight people. And I walked in the room, closed the door, and everyone's quiet. Literally, I mean, come on. Two or three conversations didn't just happen to end  at right the exact same moment I walked in the door. But you know, I open my mouth, I say a couple words, I make a joke, and it lightens everything up for them, and they feel, "OK, that's all right. That's cool."
就是那种期待感。我走进主房间。 desk后面有几个人，两三个人在闲逛。他们至少在进行两场对话，甚至可能三场。你知道，不同的人群。人不多，六到八个。我走进房间，关上门，每个人都静了下来。我的意思是，得了吧。两三场对话不可能刚好在我走进门的那一瞬间同时结束。但你知道，我开口说话，说几句话，讲个笑话，气氛就轻松了，他们觉得，“OK，那没事。那是酷的。”
But I only am able to do that because I know that if I prove to them that I'm from out of the country, then they'll feel comfortable again, like they're not having-- like, it's something that they can feel cool about. Every time I see somebody, I try to talk and make witty jokes so that it's easier.
但我只有在证明给他们看我来自国外时才能做到这一点，然后他们就会感到舒服，就像他们不是在……就像那是他们可以感到酷的事情。每次我见到别人，我都试着交谈，讲点机智的笑话，这样更容易。
In the morning, the sound journey people were at it again. They sat cross-legged in a tight circle with their eyes closed. And when the man in the middle swirled his didgeridoo around the head of an entranced, red-haired woman, a steady stream of spit splattered onto her forehead and her eyelids. She didn't seem to notice. As we were driving out of Rustler's, someone approached the car and gave us a bulging sandwich bag full of marijuana and a bumper sticker. It said, "Pot will save the world."
早晨，“声音之旅”的人又在折腾了。他们闭着眼睛在紧凑的圆圈里盘腿坐着。当中间的那个男人把他的迪吉里杜管在一位入迷的红发女人的头周围旋转时，唾液不断喷溅在她的额头和眼皮上。她似乎没注意到。当我们开车离开盗贼山谷时，有人走近车子，给了我们一个装满大麻的鼓鼓的袋子和一个保险杠贴纸。上面写着：“大麻将拯救世界。”
Drugs are the fundamental thing. Drugs is the cause of all the other vile things that is happening in our country.
毒品是根本原因。毒品是导致我们国家发生所有其他邪恶事情的原因。
In a mosque in Cape Town, we met a group called PAGAD, short for People Against Gangsterism And Drugs. They're a  little like that group DARE that we have back in the States, except instead of soccer moms, these guys are Islamic fundamentalists.
在开普敦的一座清真寺里，我们遇到了一个叫PAGAD的组织，是“反对黑帮和毒品的人们”的缩写。他们有点像我们在美国有的那个叫DARE的组织，只是这里不是足球妈妈，而是一群伊斯兰原教旨主义者。
[PRAYING]
[祈祷声]
While hundreds of Muslims pray in a huge main hall, we're in a small classroom off to the side. Sitting across from Josh and I are three PAGAD spokesmen, crammed into tiny desks meant for elementary students. Despite the 80-degree weather, they're wearing heavy ski jackets. They each have their own cellular phones, which interrupt us constantly throughout the interview. Their leader is As-Salaam [? Tohfi ?], a giant Indian man with enormous hands. He dabs his brow with a light blue terrycloth hanky.
当数百名穆斯林在巨大的大厅里祈祷时，我们在旁边的一间小教室里。坐在乔什和我对面的是三名PAGAD发言人，挤在小学校生用的课桌里。尽管气温高达80度，他们还是穿着厚重的滑雪夹克。他们每个人都有手机，在采访过程中不断打断我们。他们的领袖是阿斯萨拉姆·托菲，一个有着巨大手掌的印度大个子。他用一块浅蓝色的毛巾擦着额头。
If you go to parties tonight, to nightclubs where you go, what is the reality of that is to get drunk, to get zonked out of your minds through some kind of drug. Is this what we want? Is this what God intended when he created us as human beings? God Almighty curses us for these things. So we will never have peace in our lives.
如果你今晚去派对，去你去的那种夜总会，现实就是通过某种毒品变得酩酊大醉，变得神魂颠倒。这是我们要的吗？这就是上帝创造我们人类时的本意吗？全能的上帝诅咒这些事情。所以我们生命中永远不会有和平。
PAGAD is famous for their method of getting people to just say no. They go to a drug dealer's house, pull him into the street, and set him on fire. There had been an incident like this six month earlier. A drug dealer had been burned to death in the street. And PAGAD felt their part in the incident had been misrepresented in the press. Their legal adviser, who had been quiet until then, explained PAGAD's side.
PAGAD以其让人们“拒绝毒品”的方法而闻名。他们去毒贩家，把他拖到街上，然后放火烧掉他。六个月前发生过类似的事情。一个毒贩在街上被活活烧死。PAGAD觉得他们在新闻界被曲解了。在此之前一直保持沉默的法律顾问解释了PAGAD的立场。
A group of people went to ask this specific person, "Please, can you stop with your drug dealing? Because the people is suffering." They were met with gunfire from three meters inside the house. 17 people were shot at from behind bulletproof windows to people standing on a pavement which is two meters wide. So people was firing three meters into a crowd of about 5,000.
一群人去问那个特定的人，“请你停止毒品交易好吗？因为人们在受苦。”他们遭到了房子里三米远处的枪击。人群中有17人遭到防弹窗后的人射击，而他们正站在两米宽的人行道上。所以有人在朝约5000人的拥挤人群中射击。
5,000 people. As I sat there imagining what I would do if 5,000 people showed up at my doorstep, the legal adviser turned to us.
5000人。当我坐在那里想象如果有5000人出现在我家门口我会怎么做时，法律顾问转向了我们。
Where were you last night?
你们昨晚在哪里？
Where was I?
我在哪里？
Last night.
昨晚。
As I fumbled for an answer, [? Tohfi ?] explained how drinking, naked dancing, nightclubs, and abortions are all destroying the new South Africa.
当我笨拙地寻找答案时，托菲解释了饮酒、裸体跳舞、夜总会和堕胎是如何摧毁新南非的。
[PRAYING]
[祈祷声]
Outside the mosque, there was a wall of graffiti-- "Kill Jews," "Kill Americans," "Hezbollah." Everywhere we turned in South Africa, people seemed to be looking for quick and easy solutions to massive and complex problems. Whether that meant belonging to an alternative community or being an anti-drug crusader, killing Americans and burning drug dealers or smoking dope.
在清真寺外，墙上有涂鸦——“杀掉犹太人”、“杀掉美国人”、“真主党”。在南非，无论我们走到哪里，人们似乎都在为巨大而复杂的问题寻找快速简便的解决方案。无论是属于一个另类社区，还是做一个反毒品十字军，杀掉美国人、烧死毒贩，还是吸大麻。
It was time to return to Johannesburg to say goodbye to Josh's family and then escape from South Africa. We had been getting along fine since we left the Seftels two weeks earlier. No fighting. But now, with only four hours of highway between us and them, the tension returned. I was driving. Josh and the microphone were facing me. They had me cornered.
是时候回到约翰内斯堡和乔什的家人告别，然后逃离南非了。自从两周前离开塞夫特尔家，我们相处得很融洽。没有吵架。但现在，距离和他们见面只有四个小时的车程，那种紧张感又回来了。我正在开车。乔什和麦克风正对着我。他们把我围住了。
I get the sense that when you meet a white person here, you make the assumption that they're racist until proven innocent.
我有一种感觉，当你在这里见到白人时，你会默认他们是种族主义者，除非证明他们无辜。
I don't think whiteys here are automatically racist.
我不觉得这里的白人自动就是种族主义者。
I mean, that's what you said before. I'll play the tape for you a little bit later. But you did say that.
我的意思是，你之前就是这么说的。稍后我会给你放一下录音。但你确实那么说了。
Well, I'm sure that I did not say there are active or inactive racists and there are not two categories. And we can replay the tape as many times, Mr. Seftel, as we need to.
嗯，我敢肯定我没说过只有活跃或不活跃的种族主义者，没有其他分类。塞夫特尔先生，我们可以根据需要把录音重放多少次都行。
This was one of those arguments where you just go over the same tiny points over and over again. I didn't catch on at first. They all seemed like reasonable questions. But then I realized what he was looking for. Josh didn't want my opinion on racism or the innocence of whites. Josh wanted me, as a black person, to admit that his white South African family were the good guys.
这是一场争论，你们只是反复在这些细小点上纠缠。起初我没反应过来。它们看起来都像是合理的问题。但后来我意识到他在找什么。乔什不需要我对种族主义或白人清白的意见。乔什要的是，作为黑人，我承认他的南非白人家人是好人。
I love round shapes. And I built the plan of this house in the shape of a big breast with the fireplace being the nipple, three-dimensionality thrusting through double stories. We can then have a look at this anthropomorphic, habitable woman!
我喜欢圆形的形状。我把这个房子的平面图设计成巨大的乳房形状，壁炉是乳头，立体地穿透两层楼。我们可以来看看这个拟人化的、适宜居住的女人！
Back in Johannesburg, my cousin Louis took us on a tour of his latest masterpiece. Louis is an architect.
回到约翰内斯堡，我的表兄路易斯带我们参观了他最新的杰作。路易斯是个建筑师。
It's a two-story house still under construction. It doesn't really look like a huge breast. It's just got lots of curved walls and curved ceilings and a lot of breasty ornamentation.
那是一栋还在建设中的两层楼房子。它看起来并不像巨大的乳房。它只是有很多弯曲的墙壁和弯曲的天花板，以及很多像乳房一样的装饰。
There we are. So here, have a quick view at this round facade over here. OK.
我们到了。在这里，看一眼这边这个圆形的立面。好的。
Well, let me ask you this. Why do you put so many breast shapes in your architecture?
嗯，我问你这个。为什么你的建筑里放了这么多乳房形状？
Well, I'll tell you why. People have an immediate response. I've taken people into my breasts, and they are so moved, and they are so stunned. They can't quite work out why they like these spaces. But they like these space because they feel hugged and encompassed by them.
嗯，我告诉你为什么。人们会有直接的反应。我带人进了我的乳房，他们深受感动，惊呆了。他们说不出为什么喜欢这些空间。但他们喜欢这些空间，因为他们感到被拥抱和包围。
It was hard to dislike Louis. He was such an entertainer, I don't even think he took himself seriously. In our time in Johannesburg, he took us out, offered to lend us his car, invited friends of his over so we'd have people to meet. The more I spent in South Africa, the harder and harder it was  for me to tell the good guys from the bad guys.
很难不喜欢路易斯。他是个艺人，我觉得他甚至没把自己当回事。在约翰内斯堡期间，他带我们出去，主动提出借车给我们，邀请他的朋友过来，这样我们就能见到人。我在南非待的时间越长，就越难分辨好人和坏人。
But there were still times I didn't know what to make of people like Louis. For instance, camped out in the middle of a half-built house in the rain were at least a half dozen black men who had built a fire in the middle of the living room.
但仍然有几次，我不知道如何看待路易斯这样的人。例如，在雨中露宿在半成品的房子中间的，至少有半打黑人，他们在客厅中间生了一堆火。
Who are those guys in the rain by the fire?
雨中火堆旁的那几个家伙是谁？
By the fire, these are workers. Traditionally in South Africa, the workers live on site. These guys--
火堆旁，那是工人。在南非的传统中，工人住在现场。这几个人……
Where do they live?
他们住在哪里？
They live here. This is where they live.
他们住在这里。这就是他们住的地方。
On the cement floor?
在水泥地上？
Yeah, they live on the cement floor, and they are the builders of the house. They're casuals, laborers, they're semi-skilled, they're bricklayers and blasters and stuff. And they come to-- and what's great about it is they're using the house in the way the house is meant to be used. Except, I'd like them to put the fire inside there, in the fireplace where it was meant to be.
是啊，他们住在水泥地上，他们是这房子的建造者。他们是临时工，劳工，半熟练工人，是砌砖工和爆破工之类的。他们来到——最棒的是他们以房子本应使用的方式使用它。只是，我希望他们把火放在里面，放在壁炉里，那才是它该在的地方。
But let's go into the lounge. This is the great lounge. Good evening, gentlemen. Good evening. How are you? Good. We have a reporter here from America. He's going to tell a wonderful story about this house. Anyway--
但我们去客厅吧。这是大客厅。晚上好，先生们。晚上好。你们好吗？好。我们这里有位来自美国的记者。他要讲一个关于这房子的美妙故事。总之……
He showed us the kitchen and the bedrooms and the living room and a small servants' quarters attached to the side of the house.
他给我们看了厨房、卧室、客厅和附在房子侧面的一间小仆人宿舍。
And here are the servants' quarters. They have their own little suite and yard.
这里是仆人宿舍。他们有自己的套房和院子。
Is it nice in there?
里面好吗？
Beautiful. Lovely main bedroom and bathroom and kitchenette. Very nice.
很漂亮。可爱的卧室、浴室和小厨房。非常好。
That's going to be a mainstay of Africa then. Servants forever.
那会是南非的支柱了。仆人永远存在。
Absolutely. Servants are here in Africa to stay forever. And in fact, we must make them very nice because maybe, in a couple of years, we will move into the servants' quarters and the servants will move into the house. So you must always make them very nice.
绝对。非洲的仆人会永远存在。事实上，我们必须让他们过得好，因为也许过几年，我们就会搬进仆人宿舍，而仆人会搬进大房子。所以你必须总是让他们过得很好。
Wait, can you say that again?
等等，你能再说一遍吗？
What I'm saying is that there was in the bylaws of the old South Africa a law that your servants' quarters had to be very small and minimum-sized, and they had to have very high windows not overlooking a public space. Now servants' quarters are being made more luxurious and they're more like a little kind of garden cottage, granny flat kind of thing, because we might have to move into them one day and rent the house after the servants.
我说的是，旧南非的法规里有一条法律，仆人宿舍必须非常小、面积最小，而且窗户必须很高，不能俯瞰公共空间。现在仆人宿舍建得更奢华了，更像是花园小屋、老人公寓那种东西，因为我们以后可能不得不搬进去住，把大房子租出去。
On this last visit to Johannesburg, we stayed with my family at Dolly's house. And this time, they really felt like family. Late one night after Rich went to sleep, I talked with Dolly in the kitchen about the ups and downs of my love life. She urged me to marry a Jewish girl. It was just like talking to any of my relatives.
这次回到约翰内斯堡，我们和我的家人一起住在多莉家。这一次，他们真的感觉像家人了。有一天深夜，里奇睡着后，我和多莉在厨房里聊起我爱情生活的起伏。她劝我娶个犹太女孩。简直就像和我任何一个亲戚聊天一样。
When I first got to South Africa, I had been more willing to judge Dolly and the others. But now that I had seen more of the country, I didn't feel that way anymore. I guess at some level, it just didn't feel right to judge family in the same way that judging your parents harshly for having different opinions than you do doesn't feel right. But Rich wasn't so sure.
我刚到南非时，更倾向于评判多莉和他们其他人。但现在我已经看了更多这个国家，我不再有那种感觉了。我想在某种程度上，像这样评判家人确实感觉不对，就像严厉地评判父母因为他们有和你不同的意见感觉也不对。但里奇不这么肯定。
I don't feel skeptical of my family, my relatives here. I think you do. I think you feel a little bit skeptical of them.
我并不怀疑我的家人，我在那里的亲戚。我觉得你有。我觉得你对他们有一点怀疑。
Well, I mean, how couldn't you? They're rich, they've got bad-ass houses, they've got servants, you know. It's like people living in the South that still have domestic slaves. I mean, I guess it is a job for somebody, but it just gives you bad reminders of what it was and what was.
嗯，我的意思是，怎么可能不会呢？他们有钱，有混蛋一样的豪宅，有仆人，你知道。这就像那些仍然有家奴的南方人。我的意思是，我猜这对某人来说是一份工作，但这只会让你产生关于它曾经是什么的糟糕提醒。
So do you like the Seftels or do you not like the Seftels?
那你喜欢塞夫特尔一家吗，还是不喜欢？
I think they're good people, and I'm glad we had a chance to meet them.
我觉得他们是好人，很高兴我们有机会见到他们。
But?
但？
But--
但……
They're still rich and white--
他们依然很有钱，依然是白人……
Yeah.
是的。
--at the end of the day.
……到最后。
At the end of the day, when the chips are cashed in, they still all have servants.
到最后，筹码兑现时，他们依然都有仆人。
Do you feel like if you were here, you would have done more or less than-- what position would you be in in the Seftel family, if you were here? Do you think you would have gotten involved in the struggle, or--
你觉得如果你在这里，你会比……如果在这个塞夫特尔家族，你会处于什么位置？你觉得你会参与斗争吗，或者……
I don't know. It's too hard to know. I mean, there's so many variables. I would hope that I would have been involved in some way. It's like, how can you guess what you would have done? You never know.
我不知道。太难知道了。有太多变量。我希望我能以某种方式参与。这就像，你怎么能猜到你会做什么？你永远不知道。
Another day, another dinner with Josh's family. Our goodbye dinner. The conversation revolved around a few ongoing obsessions.
又一天，又一次和乔什家人的晚餐。我们的告别晚餐。谈话围绕着一些持续的执念展开。
Did you hear the news today about this new gang that's going around? They're raping young women.
你今天听到关于这群到处作恶的新帮派的新闻了吗？他们在强奸年轻女性。
On this visit, they seem more beleaguered than anything else. They told us about all their friends who'd been robbed and attacked. Molly explained how she'd been mugged at knife point.
这次拜访，他们看起来比什么都更像受害者。他们告诉我们关于他们所有被抢劫和攻击的朋友。莫莉解释了她是如何被持刀抢劫的。
I'm always looking at myself in the glass in the windows. And as I look, I see two tight-buttoned young men jump out of the shadows. And so I jumped into the street. And they followed me. They grabbed my bag. And they were pulling me along the ground. And I was screaming. I mean, I had every sound coming from me. I don't know where it came from.
我总是看着玻璃窗里的自己。看着看着，我看到两个紧扣纽扣的年轻人从阴影里跳出来。于是我跳进了街上。他们跟着我。他们抢了我的包，把我在地上拖。我尖叫着。我发出了一切声音。我不知道声音从哪里来的。
And they must have been doing this for about three minutes, when coming towards us was an elderly white couple. They must have been in their '70s. And the man pulled out a gun, and he shot the one on this side of me. And I said, "And him too! Him too!"
他们一定是做了大约三分钟，这时一对老白人夫妇朝我们走来。他们一定有70多岁了。那个男人掏出枪，击中了我不远处的那个人。我说：“还有那个！那个也要！”
Not long ago, Molly had been famous and powerful. She was an actress who had been in lots of plays and a few films. She was the first white actress to appear on stage with a black. Her husband Monty had been a politician and had served as the mayor of Johannesburg during the '70s. But he died a few months before we arrived. Now she lived by herself in a big house with a big wall surrounding it. She was alone, except for her black servants.
不久前，莫莉还很有名，很有权势。她是一位女演员，演过很多戏，拍过几部电影。她是第一位与黑人同台演出的白人女演员。她的丈夫蒙蒂曾是一名政客，在70年代担任过约翰内斯堡市长。但他去世于我们到达前几个月。现在她独自住在一栋巨大的房子里，四周有高墙环绕。除了黑人仆人，她孑然一身。
One of the turning points in her life as a South African, one of the moments that changed her from an activist into the person she's become, was the day that the Seftels had waited for for years, the day Nelson Mandela was released from prison. The day started off just fine.
她作为南非人生命中的转折点之一，改变她从一个活动家变成现在这样的人的时刻之一，就是塞夫特尔一家等待了多年的那一天，纳尔逊·曼德拉出狱的那一天。那一天开始得挺好的。
Well, it was total euphoria. Our family got on a plane and we flew to Cape Town and we stood in the square and waited for Mandela to come. And we waited and waited and waited and waited. And in the meantime, in the-- and it got hot as Hades. My friend who was with me, she was punched in the stomach and her camera was stolen. It was an enormous crowd of people. And they were crushing you and crushing-- eventually, you didn't have any space to breathe. And we must have been there for about six hours when we decided we must get out of here, because we began to fear for our safety. It was that sort of encroachment on our territory. And this is what's happening now.
嗯，那是完全的狂喜。我们一家上了飞机，飞往开普敦，站在广场上等待曼德拉到来。我们等啊等啊等啊等啊。与此同时……变得像地狱一样热。和我在一起的朋友，肚子被打了一拳，相机被偷了。那是一群庞大的人群。他们挤着你，挤着你……最终，你没有任何呼吸空间。我们一定在那里待了大约六个小时，才决定必须离开这里，因为我们开始担心自己的安全。那种对我们领域的蚕食就是这样。而现在发生的就是这种情况。
The new South Africa wasn't working out the way they expected. They complained that since the ANC took power, the mail service is horrible, there's litter in the streets, the government's corrupt.
新南非并没有按照他们预期的那样运作。他们抱怨自从非国大掌权以来，邮政服务极其糟糕，街道上有垃圾，政府腐败。
And they're scared. I mean, they're scared in their own homes.
而且他们很害怕。我的意思是，他们在自己的家里感到恐惧。
So that's what we've become. We're not a threat to anybody. We pay our taxes and timidly tiptoe through the land, hoping nobody will mug us.
这就是我们变成的样子。我们对任何人都不构成威胁。我们纳税，胆怯地在这个国家小心翼翼地行走，希望没人会抢劫我们。
Now, most of the young people in the family are leaving. One of Molly's children has emigrated, and one of Harold's. And another of Harold's sons is probably leaving soon. Harold told me that in 15 years, there will be hardly any Seftels left in South Africa.
现在，家族中的大多数年轻人都在离开。莫莉的一个孩子移民了，哈罗德的一个孩子也移民了。哈罗德的另一个儿子可能很快也要走了。哈罗德告诉我，15年后，留在南非的塞夫特尔一家可能所剩无几。
Yeah, there's one family, and it's a family that has perhaps a greater commitment to South Africa then, say, the average white family. And that, I think, is a microcosm that tells you what's happened.
是啊，这是一个家庭，这个家庭也许比一般的白人家庭对南非有更大的承诺。我认为这是一个微观的缩影，告诉了你发生了什么。
Even at this last dinner, even getting along with them as well as we were, there were still things about my South African relatives we didn't completely understand. And it might have been impolite, but we just asked them over and over. What did they do during apartheid, if they felt guilty?
即使在最后这次晚餐，即使我们和他们相处得很好，关于我的南非亲戚，仍然有一些我们无法完全理解的地方。这可能不礼貌，但我们反复问他们。在种族隔离期间他们做了什么，如果他们感到内疚的话？
No, I didn't feel guilty.
不，我没感到内疚。
I didn't feel--
我不觉得……
No, guilt's the wrong word for us. We don't feel guilty.
不，内疚这个词对我们来说用错了。我们不觉得内疚。
No.
不。
No such word.
没那回事。
What's the right word?
哪个词才对？
I think, disappointment, perhaps.
我想，失望吧，也许。
We are guilty to the extent that--
我们感到内疚的程度是……
Oh, no. We're guilty in the other way. But not because--
噢，不。我们以另一种方式感到内疚，但不是因为……
We lived through the apartheid years. We didn't take up arms. We benefited. But in our own little way, we kind of contributed. I know that Harry--
我们经历了种族隔离的岁月。我们没拿枪。我们从中获益了。但在我们的小范围内，我们多少有点贡献。我知道哈里……
I mean, the fact of the matter is--
我的意思是，事实是……
What else could we have done?
我们还能做什么？
No, but the critical point is--
不，但关键点是……
The government was so oppressive.
政府太压迫了。
No, but now, let's make this point.
不，但现在，咱们提出这一点。
We could have done what the Firsts did. What Ruth First did. She went to jail. And her family was destroyed. But we didn't want that.
我们可以做“第一”家族做过的事。露丝·第一做过的事。她进了监狱。她的家庭被毁了。但我们不想要那样。
But the important point is the fact that we've stayed, we made a contribution. Surely, the fact that we were here and helped to teach and to educate and to treat the sick and so on and so forth. That was surely far better than being in Boston. All right? We weren't activists. Absolutely right. But while we were here, surely we were making a contribution which we could never have made in Boston or in New York.
但重要的是，我们留下来了，我们做出了贡献。可以肯定的是，我们在这里帮助教书、教育、治疗病人等等。这肯定比待在波士顿要好得多。好吧？我们不是活动家。绝对正确。但当我们在这里时，我们肯定做出了我们永远无法在波士顿或纽约做出的贡献。
So that was it. Now that we're back in the States, Rich and I never really talk about what happened in South Africa. I guess we've said everything there is to say to each other.
事情就是这样。现在回到美国，里奇和我从来不真正讨论在南非发生的事。我想我们该对彼此说的话都已经说完了。
It's been several months since we've been back and we haven't had a single fight.
回来已经好几个月了，我们没吵过一次架。
Josh Seftel is a documentary filmmaker who made the film Taking on the Kennedys. Rich Robinson works for a business consulting firm. After coming home to the United States, he moved to Brazil for six months on business. Alone.
乔什·塞夫特尔是一名纪录片制作人，制作了电影《挑战肯尼迪》。里奇·罗宾逊在一家商业咨询公司工作。回到美国后，他因公去巴西待了六个月。一个人。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Paul Tough, Nancy Updike, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Production help from Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and Sylvia Lemus.
我们的节目今天由艾莉克斯·斯皮格尔和我制作，保罗·塔夫、南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德协助。特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。制作帮助来自亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿、豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和西尔维娅·勒穆斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website www.thisamericanlife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果您想购买本节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，号码是312-832-3380。或者您知道，可以在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢运营该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who walks up to me at the end of every single show we do and declares--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他每期节目结束时都会走到我身边宣布——
It was an amazing experience. I actually still feel quite out of my body. Really.
那是一次令人惊叹的体验。我实际上仍然感到我的灵魂脱离了肉体。真的。
I'm Ira Glass. Happy Independence Day. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。独立日快乐。下周同一时间继续带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
And thank you for creating the space to help me let go. I'm just feeling incredibly emotional.
感谢你创造了这个空间来帮助我释放。我感到无比激动。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。